deadly chaos in beirut this hour several
people have been killed and more than a
dozen injured after gunfire erupted
during a protest
people ran for cover as a demonstration
against the lead judge investigating
last year's massive blast at the city's
port turned violent the protest was
organized by hezbollah and its allies
it's not yet clear what triggered the
gunfire prime minister najib makati has
called for calm and the army has been
deployed
for more on the latest let's cross over
to barrett to our correspondent basilar
really basil what's the situation like
right now where you are
i can say that
in the last 10 minutes the situation is
settled down perhaps i didn't hear any
gunshots before that the clashes between
the lebanese armed horses
and the gunman that was so heavy uh it
was the highest and the most critical
clashes since morning
i had at least five rpgs that were just
exploded just behind me at that
roundabout where the disarmed personnel
standing by
uh according to the minister of uh
foreign affairs he counted at least six
dead and sixteen critically injured at
the moment uh according to the latest
info that i have right now that the uh
commandos in the armenian forces the
special forces are taking the lead uh in
the in the area behind me uh in order to
put an end to all these clashes the as i
said the rpg their target toward the the
laf the japanese armed forces i don't
know until this moment if there's any
casualties among the
japanese armed personnel it's not clear
yet or we know at this moment that there
is at least six dead and 16 injured
according to the minister of foreign
affairs well this protest is linked to
last year's massive blast at the city's
port that has killed more than 200
people how much is that incident still
affecting people
in fact the the situation regarding the
uh blast the portuguese didn't put an
end uh in lebanon since last year uh in
every week there's weekly uh protest
demonstration for the families of the
victims and this explosion uh start to
take a political track uh some they
believe that it's uh the the judge who
taking the lead in this investigation uh
vitar mainly uh he's accused by
hezbollah and israelites that he's
performing his uh his take is not taking
the the the investigation seriously i
mean which means that he's not following
the rules uh of law and he's uh uh doing
such uh taking track in in a way that
might uh might accuse some uh uh his
wildlife perhaps and some of his allies
they they claimed this thing so they
tried to put an end to to make this
judge quit through the cabinet but
according to the law this couldn't be
done so there's a couple inside the
cabinet meeting two days ago and just
led to to postpone the meetings to next
week and today they they they asked for
this gathering mass gathering and for
facing the minister of justice to
protest against the judge but what
happened that the the uh these violence
take over they they uh
they were some gunmen they shoots
against the protest our office the
valley office which is just near by on
this roundabout was hitted by this
gunshots the studio was affected
directly by these gunshots uh thanks god
all the team is well and we are all
secured up to this moment
so we think that the situation is uh let
me say that as well that this is the
most difficult and the most dangerous
escalation that occurred in beirut since
2008 hopefully that the main art forces
will put an end to this escalation
before before night they're trying to do
so that's why we said they said that
they asked the commandos and the special
forces to interfere in these clashes
thank you very much dw correspondent
bassala reedy in beirut for us